it took five months of negotiations
several emergency meetings numerous
proposals counter proposals and the
longest EU summit on record but now it's
official Greece has a deal shahbaz go
safety it was a good night for Europe
and a good day yeah board rule for more
than 17 hours eurozone leaders fought
tooth and nail over the details what
finally emerged was a three-year rescue
plan worth up to 86 billion euros more
than Alexis tsipras had asked for but
the deal comes at a high price for him a
draconian package of austerity measures
reforming the pension system broadening
the tax base privatisations and spending
cuts all measures Greek voters rejected
in a referendum merely a week ago the
decision gives Greece a chance to get
back on the track on track with the
support of European partners it's also
avoids the social economic and political
consequences that negative outcome would
have brought I welcome the progress and
the constructive position of Greece that
helps to bring back trust among eurozone
partners
a deal on the table but Greece's
capitulation to most of its creditors
demands has also met harsh criticism
several EU officials attacked the
toughness of the new bailout terms in
athens tsipras government coalition
partners the independent greeks tweeted
we've reached our limits they want to
crush us no more we've had enough the
talks also drove a wedge between the
leaders of France and Germany Francois
Hollande wanted fewer Angela Merkel more
commitments from the Greeks and the
German leader ultimately had the upper
hand well the arm ya ligi gefunden by
the industry some ways that follow what
I have always said on a one-hand
solidarity by the Member States on the
other hand responsibility and ownership
by the affected country for in the food
we succeeded even though the most
important currency that of trust and
reliability has been lost in the past
weeks the Vista severe wonk delimiters
for talent yes Ozzie oven and our
fellows knock on door via a shuttered
Vaughn is eurozone leaders now on Athens
to prove that it can follow through
politicians there have only 48 hours to
do so by Wednesday several of the
reforms need to be approved by the
Parliament that could be the last
installment of the Greek drama